being a real-estate agent
opens doors to new heights but it also
puts a cachaca wall in a precarious
position his customers prefer using
hawala which is illegal in India the
buyers use a network of money brokers
without actually moving the cash and
because it doesn't go through the
regular channels the payments dodge
taxes leaving government's out of pocket
the equivalent of billions of euros in
lost revenue rather than transferring
the funds directly the hawala system
uses middlemen a buyer gives the money
to a local hawala broker who then
contacts another middlemen close to the
seller this second contact then pays the
seller directly the transfer is quick
and there's no record the system is
widely used in Muslim countries in some
nations many poor people rely on hawala
because it's often cheaper and more
reliable than traditional banks so many
don't see anything wrong with it
how can people say this is illegal it
helps and supports poor people minimal
costs bring maximum efficiency with I
give you in Tumkur gem a maximum of
gulaab since the system is opaque it
also provides a way to mask money
transfers to fund criminal activities
and it is also used by terrorist groups
to move money around